barely Pirates have overthrown
Cinderella's Kingdom and have commenced
with the traditional Friday night
fireworks you should we send them for 46
seconds of logos at this point I would
have known how long was up there
underwater anyway and what luck two
random fishermen come along and catch
him in their net if they hadn't come by
when they did he probably only would
have had another 24 hours underwater
before he died not to be confused with
Cadiz Kentucky wait there is a good to
use Kentucky Wow your majesty
go him up in a fishing net if you got a
man a fishing net explain why your
wetter than he is no I told you one side
alone died 200 years ago expositional
arguing his Fountain of Youth why is the
name of this movie on Stranger Tides and
not the Fountain of Youth in case you
can be used it with London glitter I
guess the movie expects the shot of
money changing hands to explain away the
fact that Jack Sparrow is currently
posing as a judge but a lot more
information is needed for this to make
any sense - Jack arrived in London with
gobs of cash to pay off all the guards
and all the lawyers that would
presumably be an obstacle for posing as
judge wouldn't ever be at least one
incorruptible person who would keep Jack
from posing as a judge and on top of all
that
how does no one recognize that doesn't
remotely sound or look like the actual
judge yeah the woman you're finding
guilty verdict means he'll hang does the
phone and just get to unilaterally
decide the verdict without any
deliberation with the jury also why does
a jury even exist in this trial he
arranged to transport this prisoner to
the Tower of London jack had enough cash
on him to pay off all these people so he
could be a judge why didn't you just pay
people off so he and Gibbs could escape
without all the fanfare last I heard you
had held offense find the sounds from
the view you mean the object of Seiler
folklore the two sailors from the
previous scene made a significant
discovery about how convenient not at
this double-cross take place did this
driver go to somebody in the British
government and say hey Jack Sparrow is
going to make a daring escape with his
buddy gets but if you pay me more money
than he did I'll deliver him to you
instead why not just pay the driver
money for the information and stop Jack
Sparrow before he makes the escape will
you waste time on Jack trying to eat a
pastry while being chained to a gold
chair
so both someone up please remove these
insan okay you can persuade your captors
to remove your chains if you're annoying
enough and also even though they know
the legend of Jack Sparrow they've never
heard about his many many escapes wreak
havoc that's racist you do know the way
to the fountain you could guide an
expedition they still want him to guide
the expedition even though he lost the
map and he's a pirate and a captain why
put Barbosa in the room when you can
dramatically reveal him also Barbosa
could have cleared up this is this the
real Jack Sparrow argument within
seconds but we had to sit through two
minutes of that nonsense anyway are
those his qualifications for being the
captain of the kingship our
communication skills previous sailing
experience and being in all the other
movies a little rewarded with the high
station sodas ah I can't tell if this
overacting is getting worse as the scene
progresses or if I'm just getting more
annoyed by it jack is not immediately
shot right after tapping both these
guards in the nuts also escaping via nut
tap and then the King's Guard escorted
by a plate pastries you movie who
choreographed this escape Rube Goldberg
this guard has a gun but still opts for
a brisk run down the stairs instead of
shooting also I realize we can't see
jack but why couldn't they see jack he's
hiding behind the table if you're facing
the table but if you're running towards
the left side Jack is just crouching
behind it in plain view I'm honestly
surprised Rob Marshall didn't just walk
in and hand Jack a sword ago this
electrical outlet and this electrical
outlet and this HVAC vent a few things
it takes Jack absolutely no time to get
to this position this rope designed to
hold these banners of fabric is not only
holding up a 175-pound man but it's not
even tightening with the additional
weight also no one down below sees Jack
and alerts the guards who are searching
for him those late 17th century London
have a strict no snitching policy I'm
unaware of this tassel conveniently
breaks at the very last second so we can
continue this cartoonish J scene that
will inevitably end with Jack getting
away fantastic plan let's cut the rope
so he can swing down to his escape so
the guards can chase him in the street
instead of standing under him in the
streets so he has nowhere to go I'm
gonna rename Jack Sparrow Tony Jack
Sparrow oh man he dragged Dean judi
dench into this didn't think okay why
get on the top of this carriage where
you can be seen should have just stayed
in the carriage and judi dench
goddamn it why would he do this that
cart is headed towards the Redcoats that
are chasing him also the guards are
suddenly thousands of dick lengths away
from Jack when they
we're mayor vagina links away a second
ago these two men need each other's help
to carry a board also if that's the case
they would not be able to hold Jack's
weight which they are currently ignoring
now this seems like a huge obstacle for
the guards to overcome but when we next
see them there's almost no fire and
they're still on Jack's tail but quite
honestly the movie can't seem to figure
out where these guards are at any given
moment movie is perfectly content lying
to us no one sees the man obviously
hanging from the Prancing Pony sign
Jack's dad is just hiding out near the
captain's daughter waiting 2x Mach and a
jack out of a tough situation I mean how
long was he waiting over there just in
case this app I had your footage of the
other crew everyone in London knows Jack
Sparrow is putting together a crew
except for Jack Sparrow it was too busy
raising funds to bribe the entire
British judicial system to keep up with
pirate gossip no sir the day they had a
ship you mean we don't have to leave our
current location to get exactly what we
need at this exact moment also kinda
hard to believe with all the information
the King had about Jack Sparrow being in
London that they never heard of the
captain's daughter tavern and the person
recruiting sailors here
Jack's dad is Batman somehow the room is
lit in such a way that it hides the
imposter Jack Sparrow's face it's
probably why nobody who interviewed for
the job
notice do you look like Penelope Cruz
when someone decides to run to a place
where Mayor boards prevent them from
falling I consider the sword fight to be
done until that person decides to walk
away from it why even bother chasing
this person why is every rope anyone in
this franchise grabs on to strong enough
and positioned in such a way it allows
them to swing to their desired
destination any one person online jack
is so confident in the statement he
forces this mystery person to kitchen
also I'm fairly confident that more than
one person in the world knows how to
spin around with a sword you were the
only pirate I thought I was past four
boys and everything you pulled that off
notice how he never heard her Jack
Sparrow impersonation I don't want to
question this action because part of me
approves of it but the other part of me
feels compelled to question it because
it has no purpose other than revealing
her cleavage which again I am for so
like her blouse I'm torn Jesus if we cut
out all the moments where someone tells
Jack that he's looking for the Fountain
of Youth and all the times Jack says he
could use a ship we probably should have
a solid 10 minutes off this picture was
ready to take my bow
can you what are you doing in a Spanish
convent anyway
chase position more than just three
Redcoats came running in here right so
what are the other guys doing waiting to
be tapped in just running around the
room aimlessly we have advantage it's
this kind of thoughtful nuanced writing
that really makes the series shine movie
perpetuates the myth that puncturing a
barrel with alcoholic liquid will cause
it to spew like a geyser when we arrived
at this bar there was no indication that
they were near any significant body of
water it's almost as if the environment
evolves in real-time based on what the
plot requires of it it's almost like
these guards are saying well they're
clearly gone forever no need to continue
in our pursuit okay now where the car
wait it's been 20 seconds since they
fell through the crap door and now we're
in a completely different location
forcing the mant twisties old hanging
ropes lie in your bed the way you made
so he doesn't have to tie the noose Wow
was that bit of dialogue even necessary
the map doesn't burn up immediately so
why not try and put the fire out salvage
what's there and kill gets is it because
he pulls well in the focus groups is
Disney trying to ensure kids never learn
how to read a map
I know semen but I can't imagine the
sales with giant holes in them would be
super effective huh this might yeah
about that
why was Penelope Cruz pretending to be
Jack Sparrow to recruit sailors when she
the first mate on Blackbeard ship does
Blackbeard have such a bad reputation
that he couldn't recruit anybody on his
own or did this movie just really need
some mysterious someone is impersonating
Jack Sparrow nonsense to get Jack on
this adventure
dad B's we may be steps we've been a
fortnight at the hands of a monic a
flame is the fountain yeah but while I'm
finding the fountain prevent the
one-legged man from killing it as we
find out the fountain only works by
taking the total years lived from one
person and adding them to another person
not makes you impenetrable to stab
wounds all those will soon find out this
movie doesn't know what the fountain
ritual actually does anyway so
ultimately the answer we're looking for
is this movie that should be so kind
just provide us an eddy wait you mean
just now after sailing this long here
are the Spaniards who should have a huge
head start on all the other expeditions
they have Ponce de len's book and
everything but here they are neck and
neck with the other theory on the proper
car skins I it be proper there's your
proof so now we kill Gibson follow the
Spaniards never so much has turned his
head maybe this is why they keep kids
around his vision is so impeccable he
can see what a normal man needs a
telescope to see I signed up to fail
into Jack's pattern of some Pretender
and a lady in that other than she does
keep up the Jack Sparrow routine so
these idiots don't mutiny on her for
being an imposter
it's because it wouldn't be sexy enough
Tom one of them really all of them there
are only six swords on this whole ship
also considering that they just started
talking about mutiny what was the
conversation like before this kid left
okay we're going to talk about mutiny so
we'll need swords alright what send the
child you have been monstrously deceived
God septic dead yes even jack is getting
irritated with the repetitive dialogue
instead of choreographing some real
action and fighting movie decides to
just cut cut cut cut itself to death to
create the illusion that these actors
can actually sword fight if Blackbeard
has rope telekinesis then why even
bother having a group can he just stand
on deck and command the ropes to do is
bidding should I pray for every
unfortunate soul on this hellbound this
oh come on
Florida's not that bad oh this guy
attended the Prometheus school rowing
away from things also Blackbeard wasted
a ton of flammable accelerant to kill
this one crewman that guy god dammit
Trident carving produces no blood
because the spirits of Voodoo are aware
of the reading this movie was shooting
for Wii
so did Angelica pretend to be jacked a
lure jack onto the ship somehow or were
they planning on making this trip
without jack because remember the only
reason Angelica dressed up as Jack was
because she felt like he was the only
pirate she could make believable there's
a lot missing from this backstory and
none of the explanations are good the
director said well honey your character
eat sliced apples it'll make you look
like even more an asshole
barmaid Beckford in hunger of hot fresh
have man character in movie begins
explaining things to other characters in
the movie that they surely already know
so it was about time this movie got back
to its roots can i hey you know read to
a list defunct why does she know the
ritual is it just an essential thing
she's tasked with knowing so the viewing
audience can rest assured she'll be here
for most of the movie lot from the
fountain up you this shimmering tear of
a mermaid the silver chalices of heavily
on I thought the Fountain of Youth was
supposed to be a naturally-occurring
magical body of water so how did ponce
de Lyonne figure out he needed that tear
from a mermaid and silver chalices that
he himself owned to make it work also
the movie Bremen trips off Indiana Jones
and the Last Crusade because why not
this item you may take hold the years of
life from another if that's the case
then the fountains name is incredibly
misleading why don't we change it to the
front of someone else's life it's the
mood you can explain how the black
parole you know what okay can we just
please get to the fountain without going
down all these rabbit holes I am surely
after Blackbeard why did you lie about
lying about being his daughter that what
purpose did that search they'd be drawn
to man laid like shock as this jackass
kid not been paying attention all
they've been talking about since they
got here or Myr raids
worse than shots boy both sharks and
mermaids will try to eat you but
mermaids are hot and topless days on to
a sting you can find this on page 47 of
the non fictional text how to comer made
in 10 days and they'd start using an
attack they could have used a lot sooner
than this also spider made Jack somehow
knew that mermaids would be scared of
this explosion mermaids have breasts but
they don't have nipples because the
genetics are compliant with the movies
pg-13 rating ever walk on the basis of a
conceal accepts in the fan if he says
something about seeing a second set of
footprints I'm turning it off
mermaids attack Barbosa ship but seemed
completely disinterested in the assholes
who are already on land which is a
severe departure from what they did last
night with Blackbeard's crew did they
run out of spider webs also why did they
wait to attack the ship after all the
main characters of this movie got to
land Oh
now that Barbossa ship is being sucked
look I going to get to the next place or
is this movie saying that white cat bay
is the final destination and they can
walk the rest of the way
furthermore aware of these assholes now
if it's raining on Whitecap Bay in
Barbosa can Blanca the next place then
where did Blackbeard go where it's
totally sunny why should we call from
Evernham because to yourself keep we
need them fresh and we also need to
develop a love story between the mermaid
and the philip also with this movie
joking this ritual requires fresh tears
seriously who made up these rules we
really want to be young that badly what
was removing water from the fountain and
a mermaids team and soos universe
chalices once kept with us year one
without I'm beginning to think this
movie was written by people who made
those puzzle adventure games where you
have to do some really convoluted just
to advance with no clues and no
explanation but the palms daily on the
answer was clear as day mermaid tears
and chalices here Ponce de Leon was also
a huge work fan also which came first
the Fountain of Youth or a pump de
Lyonne sounds like he's the one who made
the rules but isn't he famous for
looking for the fountain so how did he
come up with all this and if it wasn't
him and how did God come up with all
this iconic items if you read this kind
of dialogue for your main character that
might be a hint you're in need of a
second draft
she needs ass Phillip is not just a
clergyman he's also a mermaid expert you
get to choose mr. Sparrow
even though Blackbeard is I'm running
out of time he still has time for
Russian roulette if the voodoo doll
gives Jack the sensation of falling then
why doesn't he start drowning when the
doll hits water dance you think with the
amount of money of these movies continue
to make they could splurge on some
better animal CG on how much stay up to
earmark for depth wine exactly well of
course she grows legs if she's not in
water maybe that's why she never speaks
she sold her voice to an octopus drag
queen lady so she could have legs when
she's on land ha right he's young and
attractive mermaids only eat dirty old
pirates what was clear as day a few
minutes ago is now dark and foggy as if
this island changes the weather based on
whatever a movie needs at a given moment
so how did ponce de Leon's boat end up
on this clip was it placed there by the
screenwriter to set up a precarious
moment that will soon happen
mom's de Leone's buried in Puerto Rico
so I don't think he's on the right ship
sighs actually have to balance it out
further proof that there is no reason
for the ship to still be sitting here
after 200 years also how was Barbosa
able to sneak onto this boat without
calling balance issues if that boats
balance is so precarious and why was
Jack able to do the same without causing
any issues until they started sword
fighting Spanish there ahead of his
might well know their voyage wasn't
filled with pointless hijinks and
shenanigans Ponce either programmed his
dead body to be protective of the map
for some reason or he's still alive from
drinking from the fountain water and
mermaid tears problem is we find out
later that the fountain heals scar so
why would your body deteriorate and why
would you waste your time guarding a map
in this condition also I think the two
of you could probably win a fight with
the weird skeleton puppet you will not
talk Jack Phillip feels undying love for
the mermaid that he's only known for a
day which just proves that love at first
sight is real as long as you're
incredibly hot also can we all agree
that no one gives a shit about this
priest mermaid love story that begins
2/3 of the way through this movie just a
scratch so Barbosa keeps a super deadly
sword drawn dramatically raising the
risk that he could accidentally stabbed
himself not to mention giving Jack a
reason to ask about it so we'll know
about the frog poison now this Barbosa
directing this question to jack or the
director hi you deceive in that you're
not a gross middle-aged pirate man nor
are you Angelica who clearly has a thing
going with Jack process of elimination
love is still up he is in joy they say
these bees are more potent anyways where
are you getting this information how
many conversations about mermaid tears
are you having with your colleagues is
there a book to console the Spaniards
tie up Jack and Barbosa to trees that
are so far away they are in perfect
escaping range also why did Barbosa have
to go along with this Fountain of Youth
thing just to get back at Blackbeard I'm
sure there were ways much simpler than
infiltrating the British Navy to find
the magical fountain that Blackbeard is
also looking for in order to free
himself from the ropes Jack is going to
climb this entire palm tree somehow get
over the top of the palm tree and I
guess slide back down the tree like a
fireman or find some way to cartoonishly
bend the tree down you can't just have
him emerge from the leaves completely
free how did you get over those leaves
is it a magical rope to compan through
leaves how many magical ropes are in
this movie
movie did in fact go for some cartoonish
tree bending Jack through the power of
editing makes it past all these guards
using only a rope and manages to tie
them all to a tree because art imitates
life and life is stupid Jack and Gibbs
went through the trouble of catching a
pig so they could tie the chalasis to it
and make it run away if Blackbeard
didn't meet their demands seems like
there would be an easier way to do this
but I'm not making a movie to fund my
future Star Wars acquisition thankfully
Jack noticed this drop of water so that
he could eventually look through it
while at the same time looking directly
at the X that marks the spot
so why was that single drop of water
falling up when this giant pool of water
behaves like a normal pool of water such
just an indicator drop that they are
headed in the right direction aqua de
vida you have to say these words because
obviously after getting mermaid tears
locating chalices and actually finding
the location of the Fountain of Youth in
the first place you clearly haven't done
enough these people somehow here jack
over all the noise and all of them are
stopped by what jack has to say and
another is that pier still fresh I will
not have that smile in your face when I
strike you down Blackbeard's in a tough
spot on one hand if he doesn't kill
Barbosa then Barbosa is going to kill
him
on the other hand if he does kill
Barbosa that means the stupid-ass
prophecy is wrong and that will cut my
whole world of a prophecy in a movie is
wrong again only God can grant eternal
life not this vague on what if the
Spaniards came out simply to destroy the
front of you then why didn't they just
go ahead and do that they had a
tremendous lead on everyone getting to
this island and they knew the others
were coming for it furthermore couldn't
they simply just destroy the chalices
and call it a day
since you need to do all sorts of petty
to make the Fountain of Youth work
anyway
looks like the Spanish Inquisition went
to the Lois Lane school disposing of
things destroyed this provides up foe if
he really thinks that all this is both
paganism how does he explain the
floating water first off there is
apparently a mermaid route to the
Fountain of Youth
second off why did Serina use her
freedom to swim toward the fountain for
any reason I mean maybe she thought she
could save the heartthrob from Hunger
Games Catching Fire but she just gives
the chalices to Jack and pieces out so
her appearance here smells terribly of
ex machina and tuna again I gotta ask
why does this work the rules have been
stated clearly fountain adds years to
your life but there's never any
explanation about healing existing scars
or death blows I think this movie is so
Last Crusade it forgot what the power of
this water really is
I mean she totally eats him right Rach
any idea how to get her out which will
need a crossbow an hourglass three goats
one of us must learn to play the trumpet
was yelling because that is maybe this
movie is making fun of itself but this
is no sillier than what we just watch
and just as tedious heating load of
bulls washes up on the island where
Angelica has strained it o in the world
to travel as far and again I ask how to
jackknife round
well I don't want to be a pirate
please still hope again how'd you mother
here you made your point
go back who are you we're extremely hot
chicks with large breasts
let's drink I like it I know it's great
right no I regret this one it seemed
like forever claim in the glorious name
of His Majesty King nobody expects the
Spanish Inquisition various egos will
try to ship it